we're here today with Joe Kelly one of
my favorite writers of all time and oh
I'm so excited I'm doing great thank you
so much thank you for this kind words I
truly Deadpool has been the character I
have defended hardest loudest and most
charismatic Lee because spider-man you
don't have to defend Batman you don't
have to defend but Deadpool is so
synonymous with mountain dew and X Games
and a certain type of person that you
really have to find the right version of
him to show people right and and for my
money the heart you brought Deadpool and
the way you framed him as the character
that doesn't wear a mask to protect
others it's to protect the visage of
what he brings to you is is unique and
I've always loved that he's the only
character that hides his own face not
for identity because it's ugly and and
that's a lot of heart so when you first
found out about Deadpool how did you
reshape him in such a way what did you
see in him that hadn't yet been found
well I so I was relatively new at Marvel
at the time I just done a little bit of
work for them I and I just started on
daredevil I guess which was a great
opportunity and Matt Idol sin was the
editor brand-new editor at the time also
and they said hey we want to do this you
know series for Deadpool which literally
nobody thought would last six issue you
know we just need it we call them budget
Buster's like they have to spend money
before the end of the year to get that
money for the next year and so I threw
my hat in the ring and I for me I
actually really like dark stories that
like anti-heroes I love all that stuff I
really do but I was like if I had to
write this guy for a long period of time
I couldn't sustain I'm just grim and her
and whatever so the humor started to
come in and then some of the stuff
actually the masking that you're
mentioning for for me came from a Wade
story the I think it's in circle chases
the Wade yeah so where the mask gets
taken off and he's like give me back my
face like he's freaking out yeah so that
actually keyed me
into the humanity of him and like where
he's kind of broken and trying to take
that and pull it out and somebody who
hates themselves so much that they sort
of because when you think about it it's
got a healing factor but he's still
looks like this yeah me that's always
been like the deep psychology of this
how he feels so taking that but making
sure it has a you know clowny face on it
was the fun of the character so yeah my
the original pitch had him fighting like
ego the Living Planet Rock Show the
clown and like all the weirdest obscure
stuff and so I guess it was different
enough everybody else was like mercenary
tough-guy stuff that Matt took a chance
and and then we got it McGinnis and then
you know the combo was great because his
style being so light and open really
made the darker stuff feel less dark
which was huge for that character
absolutely I will be far from the first
one to say that particularly in your run
the issue where he goes back to visit
spider-man more or less is a standout
and is the one that you sort of hand
people when you're like you need to
understand what Deadpool is start here
classics vol 2 by the way thank you they
that was a great opportunity that that
was really fun and a lot of work because
it was I think mostly done by hand and
and yeah Pete woods just killing it and
slang and aping the style of the
original book and trying to make sure it
all flowed together
yeah was there any resistance to the
idea or were they like yes do it no we
totally got away with it I don't I don't
really understand how I don't know who
Matt had photos of or something but no
we did all right and as a matter of fact
we got we ran it by Stan which was which
was nerve-wracking and he gave us a very
kind this was really funny you know a
thank you for us honoring that but I
mean it was just like ridiculous and
still being so new in the industry to be
like Stan right my staff it was great
and so that yeah that issue is
particular what am I one of my favorites
for sure
so if you don't know this yet announced
yet but I did this thing for Skybound
and we're animating it and it's for my
money he is the first meta modernist
character in pop culture meta modernism
is this new wave of concept about being
both ironic and naive simultaneously be
all-knowing but naive like it's pretty
what Lord Miller doing it's shaping a
narrative where they're winking but
thanking you for winking with them right
and I feel like Deadpool really made
that mainstream when did you first
decide the fourth wall was something
that didn't exist for him
that's so funny it just felt like a
natural aspect of the comedy like I you
know my I tend to go back to my
influences as a kid right and and it's
not so much like oh I want to replicate
that stuff because adman have actually
talked about this all time especially
for taking a new like add established
property and revisiting it like red gram
it's it's not so much what were my
favorite bits mm-hmm it's what do I
remember feeling
so like you know Looney Tunes for me
where Bugs Bunny would just destroy
everybody savage everybody but with a
wink and a nod towards the audience and
it was okay that I remember Robin
Williams was always a huge influence on
me for in every stage of my life and
that playing with the audience and the
give-and-take that came from his act
mm-hmm huge influence Monty Python you
know like those are the things well yeah
really fed me so it just felt natural
that to keep the comedy from just being
one-liners or gross-out gags or whatever
it was another way to kind of poke at
the at the audience and and in the very
first issue just the gag of him
narrating his own mission not having
people look up and go like is he
actually talking about you know that
started that ball rolling so and and Ed
was totally into it so it worked out
really well in that regard now Anne
Preece took over there's a beautiful
moment I win and it's got a beautiful
label on it yeah were you reading that
what was the moment like when you
realized you were part of the fourth
wall it was fantastic no I it's a I
I generally not for any any any reason
other than habit once I'm done with a
book I generally don't go back and read
it it's just I have to mentally move on
and and it's just a hang-up of mine you
know it's never anything about whatever
creative follows but I wanted to see
what the next one was because you know
the end of my
was very Tim I wouldn't have left
Deadpool really but it was where
canceled were not canceled were canceled
canceled it was a very weird time there
were literal fan letters that kept us
alive so thank you all you fans sent
actual letters to us it really did I
mean every month it was like all the
sales are too low and they would go up
now so that was I couldn't tell stories
that way because I had to keep wrapping
things up and then reopening them so
then when when Chris priest took over
and I see Joe Kelly's good idea it was
hilarious I really did I loved it and I
thought it was a it was very touching
kind of like homage to say you know
thanks for what you did down taking the
ball you know like it was very very
funny I thought it was cool so and it
firmly established like the Deadpool we
have now like it so the path from there
because you of course you you were in
the the center of Marvel you were
writing x-men notably for both Korey and
me and but since then you've done a
million different things what has sort
of the guiding star been as you jump
between mediums and worlds and take on
all these different challenges
oh just yeah why blind luck at stupidity
no I I look for the projects that I feel
like I can bring something to that speak
to me personally you know and I'm I'm
really inspired sama Tetsu cos like for
me the king like I look at you you go
Astro Boy and Buddha and blackjack and
then like MW and an ode to kheer hero
you look at this really incredible span
of work and he would never let himself
to be pigeonholed so for me that's
critical so I love I'll do really dark
funny stuff I'll do lighter stuff I'll
do the cycle giants I'll do animation so
for me I guess it's it's just it's hard
like can I find the heart in the thing
or do I feel like there's something in
me that needs to be expressed like
whether it's a sometimes it's anger
sometimes it's you know mission
sometimes it's a you know just some
little bit of knowledge I kind of leave
you out there for my kids or whatever
you know it's just following that
Jones and and like we tell a lot of
young writers that want to get into the
business it's like what's a story that
only you can tell so that's what I try
to do to the best of my ability
with working in so many mediums what's
what's your creative process like do you
have like eight cups of coffee sit down
write like what's it like a ritual it's
going for different things yeah yeah
there's definitely too much coffee I
when I'm on the beam I'll do the
meditation thing which is good that
hasn't happened a little in a little
while I different music for different
things for sure but that's usually
project to project not genre genre
although lately I've been doing a lot of
writing to like white noise I just have
a sound machine and just leave it on
because that helps Center me a little
bit is that Pavlovian thing like you're
working now because I work from home so
it's it's generally although I do I
start my day like at the coffee shop and
kind of do that that stereotype for a
few hours just so I'm in a different
place and that's usually something like
a new book like a graphic novel or or a
script that's for me like a spec thing
that's kind of like super my time and
then later on the rest of the day when
I'm at home in my office is more man of
action work things that I you know
whatever is might ask for for the week
and then everyone smile disappear I'll
just kind of go somewhere and try to
bang out a bunch of stuff over the
course of a weekend or you know very
focused like I'm only here to write like
a burst yeah and and really try to make
like a retreat but the jumping around
from headspace the biggest the biggest
changes is the format which isn't really
that big a deal now in the beginning it
was writing for comics as fun as it is
it gives you terrible writing habits for
running for the screen really why
because the scripts can be as long as
you want right so like the courses like
alan moore could write 70 page script
for a 20 page comment write everything
animation TV film it's the page a minute
thing it just doesn't go away because
you're working with a time medium so you
have to be super economic with all your
language wearing comics like and that
microphone stand looks so cool and oh
and by the way make sure you draw five
panels on the back like you can do all
that stuff and i generally i think my
scripts were like a 22 page book go
about the 30-something page realm
because I don't do plot style I tend to
do a full script when working with
comics there's a certain amount of
collaborators that's a little it seems
more a finite then a screenplay where's
the screenplay like how am i bringing a
whole new set of like best boys and
grips like you're dealing with a
different scope of people was it
different reframing when writing the
screenplay versus writing the comic for
I killed Ryan's was did you have to
reframe how you write if I can pause
just for audience you're in a very small
group of people who created a cool
completely independent story and then
got to actually be the one who
translated it for the big screen so huge
congratulations and thank you for that
story by the way and from what I've
heard it was kind of simultaneous like
you were writing them both and kind of
alternating between formats was it hard
to like take a hat off and put it like
to so speak like format was yeah it's
funny well thank you for that yeah I
killed Ryan's is very very dear to my
heart and the the creation that story
for it was one of those like I really
have to tell this you know and I feel
like that sounds corny but stuff but but
I did I just it was in me I had to like
purge it and get the story out so I
wrote the outline said I'll start as a
comic because that was what I did and
the second I finished the comic I was
like oh let me just write it as a
screenplay too and that took a few
months to get both those done but then
yeah I did go back and forth because I
had a few artist friends that were kind
of into it but not totally were they
dropped out so I didn't find Ken until a
few years and in that time I had sent
the movie script to a friend who at the
time worked at Nickelodeon and and her
and I have very similar mind space for
like this kind of material she gave me
great notes that informed the comic so
it did go back and forth and because it
was the same story in that particular
case the medium didn't matter it wasn't
until later when we actually got to go
into production and part of the reason I
have the the good version of the
Hollywood story not that oh yeah we
stabbed the creator and left
you know with an option pinned emissions
for seven stores yeah exactly was mostly
because I just kept telling people right
up front I'm the only person who's ever
gonna write this and if that's a problem
then I'm sorry thank you it was nice to
meet you and everybody people were very
cool with that and then I had to say
that to Chris Columbus but you know I
had talked a really good game to my to
Steve and you know they have action God
sounds like I really got to say this now
and I did and he was he was very cool he
totally understood it was it was a very
personal story and once he signed off on
that it became really easy than anybody
we met after that whether it was a
financier or another producer I was like
well Chris says I was writing it yes I
am and then it got to the point where
when we were actually in production I'd
be getting calls there in Ireland or
Belgium you know various places
what should the sign say in the
background of his sounds like I don't
know and they're like what you're the
writer Chris says you know it's like
that wasn't be careful you know it was
it was really it was always wonderful
and and Anders Walters the director was
incredible
cast was amazing everybody was so great
and they were very protective of the
material and all wanted to try to make
the same movie which is the most
important version aspect of it but the
hardest part really in the killing of
your own darling sing was and both both
Chris and Anders were good at this were
to say this is perfectly in a comic it
works fine here's why it doesn't work in
a film mostly it was about breaking the
reality the movie so if you wanted to
leave people which I did with that is
this real or is this in Barbara's mind
ambiguity which i think is critical for
the story certain things had to go
because in the book it was still okay
but like if she's wearing a suit of
armor and gets punched by a bully and it
all shatters and nobody says what's over
your dorky armor and it was in her head
and you know that sort of stuff so that
those were the edits that I got from
from those guys and if they were great I
mean they
and then force me to think in a you know
in a different way for the film now in
some ways I feel like you were ahead of
the curve with this with sort of the the
D&D Renaissance our general level of
like audiences accepting some things
that are a little closer to kind of
magic realism which I think you're also
doing with Poughkeepsie right the short
film that you've just made yeah yep is
that just something that that
particularly has always spoken to you or
like are you are you excited to have
audiences more receptive to that kind of
storytelling it's great I I really hope
that that that that barometer keeps
going you know where people are willing
to accept more stuff in that land of
this is just how the universe is today
you know for me Giants was always a girl
needs help in the universe cracks open
to give her the help she needs that's my
version of it other people take it in a
different way which is fine pick up see
is this short film thank you for
bringing it up that's very kind of you
congratulations on it by the way thank
you thank you it was it was my first
shot at trying to direct something like
this and it was it was really a
wonderful experience it's been an
Alzheimer's patient who was a pretty
terrible guy in his youth and now as
he's staring down his final days you
know he's he's got a lot of regrets but
in those moments where it looks like
he's sort of in his out-of-it state he's
remembering the past but then he starts
to change it and then it has
ramifications when he sort of wakes back
up in the present and like said it's a
magical realism kind of scenario where
some people look at it and they go oh
that was just his mind and his way of
processing the end of his life and other
people go yeah he got the he got the
chance to fix things and there's certain
things you can't fix and that's part of
the story too but then the things it it
helps him realize what's actually
important which in in our case is his
granddaughter who's been by his side
this whole time so I love those stories
I hope I feel like somebody like
guillermo del toro does that so well you
know Pan's Labyrinth is for me like a
huge huge influence I mean I love that
movie to death I just recently
re-watched it with one of my kids
because they'd heard me talk about it
forever but we just never sat down to
watch it now like let's see that movie
you're always talking about does that
like to watch with your own children oh
it's awesome I what my kids are you know
they're they're older now but
although Steve will tell you that I've
shown my daughter way too many horror
movies way to CPS level like you show
her what mostly because I have a
terrible memory so I'm like Exorcist
like she'll be okay with that and it's
like oh I'm showing her once Let The
Right One In but the original version
but I fell asleep and I just dad it was
like some guy was getting blood let so
yeah hopefully you know the therapy jar
was full but yeah so video games
animation directing one of the most
iconic runs of Deadpool and now a new
iconic round of Deadpool is there
anything you haven't done yet you want
to do is there anything like on left the
creative list oh sure yeah I mean
there's always more projects obviously I
would like to ultimately direct a
feature would be the goal I'd love to
write more films you know Giants I
actually went to school for
screenwriting that was sort of my
initial training that's how I got into
Marvel they had come to our program for
looking for new talent so for awhile I
got pulled away from that and then was
able to get back to it a little bit so
yeah I mean as far as media in general I
love video games I'd love to do sort of
from the ground up a game that was you
know one of my concepts or a man of
action concept that we really shepard
and then i wouldn't mind taking a crack
at a novel I never thought I had a prose
voice and then I started messing around
at that National Novel Writing Month
thing to pump up every year we yeah
actually a really cool program and I
found like if I didn't pay attention I
could write super fast you know I was
like a thousand words an hour kind of
person and I was banging out this story
that I just started rereading I was like
oh this is fun but it's like you know
when I get my back pension on trying to
do that because we have a lot going on
so yeah but I love it all it's just
about what stories do you want to tell I
just love you know I loved and had been
lucky enough to tell stories you know I
I went to school as plenty people that
we all got that same degree and not
everybody gets to tell stories you know
what I mean and I was in the right place
at the right time and really lucky and
hooked up with with good people who
believed in me and and helped get me
where I am so yeah now I want to hog my
final two questions on Deadpool so well
I had changed what was it like coming
back for how did what were you like yeah
I miss him let's do some more Deadpool
but what Spidey this time yeah Deadpool
Spidey yeah
I fir I had been asked a few times about
Deadpool in it as a general rule I don't
I just don't go back again it's not a
it's just my own thing I feel like oh I
probably said what I had to say and and
then um Nick Lowe called me up and was
like okay look it would be spider-man
and Deadpool and Ed McGuinness like real
came in and I thought well I loved how
they've I mean Spidey Spidey is my
absolute favorite growing up that he's
my guy like no question my favorite
superhero of all time
Deadpool's of cornerstone my career and
I love him so it just seemed like it
made so much sense to to take a stab at
that that two different types of humor
and could you make it work and could
they both still be funny so the just a
mechanics a story mechanics ever were
interesting to me working with Ed again
was great and watching how everybody's
evolved over the course of time has been
cool you know I mean I
you forget that like Deadpool has been
around now 20:20 yeah yeah my Run was 20
years ago that was five years before
that yeah it was 25 years for his movie
because it was a limited process so
amazing timing yeah yeah so it was um so
so that opportunity sounded good it
sounded like a good challenge and and it
was just a ton of fun i mean and i love
i love how Deadpool's evolved with sort
of like the breakdown of certain social
mores and stuff like that so you know
his sort of pansexuality and all the
sort of
that come out where we lightly touch on
in the book and and certainly play a
little bit more for comedy maybe then
digging deep but that sort of stuff what
I wasn't doing and that was sort of new
so get to experiment with all that stuff
and Spidey's new you know current or the
status quo at the time was fun and so
yeah it was a it was like a 30-second
dilemma that went away immediately thank
you so much for knowing thank you for
having me that's great
I've done for pop culture and all the
Deadpool stuff really like changed my
life so I appreciate it thank you so
much I really appreciate